are you both doing good is it tea or
coffee compose me team oh yeah you're
rocking both in true start to fisting
the TNS off its gonna be a pinky pinky
up video thank you
we're both wearing our rings from outlaw
King
we are mr. pine but it's very nice of
them to oh you're gonna do like a
special drink thing all right now no
long Joe one of the things I don't mind
if you drink during the interview one of
the things that is fascinating about the
way David likes to work is he loves
doing these long takes where it's like
you go 15 minutes without a cut yeah
and he's shooting with four or five
cameras it's such an interesting way
because so many filmmakers don't go like
that mm mm can you sort of talk about
working with the director like that and
maybe what that brings to the table yeah
absolutely I mean it's it was it's it
was a whole new experience for me I
didn't really know what to expect and
and that continued and being surprised
so for instance and there's a sort of
courtyards scene and we ride in and we
didn't know where any of the cameras
were placed so Barry Aykroyd um you know
cinematography has come from a
documentary background so he's capturing
kind of truthful moments that aren't
necessarily the event itself you know
we're interested in stuff that surrounds
the event as well because that's what
you know that's what you know gives it
in its impact and also then with David
giving us the the freedom you know
liberating us as actors and allowing us
to play that came from the fact that he
wanted to do rolling resets he was like
never called cut let's just try you know
and I was imagine trying to configure
like the logistics of 150 supporting
artists but still doing a rolling reset
you know so they would capture them
walking back to their positions and you
know that becomes part of the language
of the the cinema and the movie itself
and was well there's reiterate what
Billy said it was a theatricality to
where it wasn't you know sometimes you
do some films you do some TV
say okay hit your mark stay there I'll
do that there there was such a freedom
because sometimes you've come many a
courtyard or you'd be on a mu or on a
hill and you yeah you knew there was
cameras around you but you weren't quite
sure where they were turned on or where
they were right where they were actually
placed so and he wouldn't yell cut at
times but it did create a very
spontaneous feeling of them of of just
of just being and of playing and then
when you know when someone doesn't say
cut and you know what's gonna be the end
of the scene you can play more you have
this freedom of expression ISM as as as
a character that you can you can stay in
that world and you can try things and
you can improvise I mean David always
said that the script presence of you
know the Babel POC the scriptures is a
guideline the script is a structure of
our story of course but within that if
there's anything that we can do to
improve a little nuances that we can add
to it and it was a great collaborative
experience with David Elia less it gave
us freedom and with Chris being us
fearless leader we am we also aver very
much was very altruistic we very much
helped each other out and and there was
no shame or no you know I've got an idea
what is it I'll try it now maybe that
would work it was nothing like you know
like being people being shot down for
having an idea that was good or bad or
indifferent that wasn't the case it was
economic of him Band of Brothers band of
sisters together and going late well
let's this because it's very challenging
material you know it's it's a story
that's never really been told before
about a man whom even Scott's many
Scott's don't actually know they know
who Robert the Bruce says he's an iconic
King he's in the 20 poem no but how did
he become the man that he became why did
they write the Declaration of Arbroath
in 1320 when it came to pass how did he
achieve all this and brings freedom
independence to a sovereign nation like
Scotland defeat an army that was a you
know
you know five times the size of heads
with her Sam
he had guerrilla tactics that the
genesis of guerrilla warfare derives
from the way Bruce would fate in Boggs
because he was heavy horse charge you
could never withstand up Scotland always
got em obliterated until blowed inhale
until Vanek born seven years later
attacking small English Garrison's he
had to use his mind rather than mate
because and that's why many ways Robert
the Bruce is arguably one of the most
greatest sort of historical tacticool
you know military geniuses that and all
of that aspect he was still a very
flawed man in many ways he's a heroic
figure but he you know I think the way
Chris portrayed him and he walked with
David and the rest of us that he he's
he's torn you know am I gonna stay with
my lines am I gonna keep my lands in
England keep my lines or but within that
he changes his mind Wallace has killed
and he's got something deep down inside
of him that says I care more about my
nation of more but my people then I do
about sort of lands and wealth and as it
well so I mean within that as many other
stories the relationship between Billy
and Prince of Wales and his father as
well as is one of you know great pain
and sort of an emotional trauma
emotional trauma shall we see
you